en el vídeo anterior encontramos la
velocidad mínima requerida para estar en
esta ruta circular de aquí que es de
27.6 kilómetros por hora lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es que veamos justo
la parte donde está haciendo este rizo
para calcular su velocidad promedio real
y voy a usar este editor de vídeo de
aquí para ver cuánto tiempo tarda en
completar la vuelta y usar esto en
conjunto con lo que sabemos de esta
circunferencia suponiendo que esto es
perfectamente circular aunque en la
imagen del vídeo tiene una forma ovoide
o un poco elíptica pero para nuestros
cálculos vamos a suponer que es
perfectamente circular les dejaré a
ustedes el reflexionar cómo afectaría
nuestros cálculos si tuviéramos una
forma elíptica veamos el vídeo
nuevamente recordemos que desde el
programa fire del canal channel five de
inglaterra así que aquí va veamos lo de
nuevo una vez más
y este de aquí es el cronómetro del
editor de vídeos y eso es en segundos
aunque en el vídeo anterior me
corrigieron que éstas no son centésimas
de segundo son cuadros y hay 30 cuadros
por segundo
así que comienza en cero según 20
cuadros y cuando lo dejamos correr llega
a los 2 segundos y 14 cuadros y como son
30 cuadros por segundo son 2 y 14 30 vos
de segundo es lo que tarda este auto en
dar esta vuelta de risa aquí va un
segundo y aquí dos segundos es casi dos
segundos y medio vamos a escribir esto
así que el tiempo y bueno recordemos que
estas son aproximaciones el tiempo
requerido para hacer esta vuelta de rizo
es de 2 14 30 2 de segundo y cuál es la
distancia que recorre si suponemos que
esto es circular aunque habíamos visto
que parece más un ovoide si suponemos
que es circular entonces la distancia
recorrida será la circunferencia de esta
pista es de 2 pin por el radio que es
igual a 2 por pi y en el vídeo anterior
encontramos que el radio era de 6 metros
así que es de 2 x pi por 6 metros
metros si queremos encontrar la
velocidad promedio o mejor dicho la
rapidez promedio ya que la velocidad
cambia constantemente debido a la
dirección pero la magnitud de la
velocidad o la magnitud de la velocidad
promedio
tendremos que dividir vamos a escribirlo
por acá rapidez promedio de la distancia
total recorrida será 12 pi metros
dividido entre el tiempo que se necesita
para hacer este recorrido que es 2 14 30
bosch de segundo saquemos nuestra
calculadora para hacer la operación y
vamos a tener que la distancia es
quitamos esto 12 por pi dividido entre
vamos a escribir esto como 2 + 14
dividido entre 30 para tener el valor
exacto cerramos paréntesis y eso nos da
en metros por segundo
15.28 vamos a redondear lo a 15.3 metros
por segundo así que la rapidez promedio
es aproximadamente igual a 15.3 metros
por segundo lo que es casi el doble de
rápido de lo que encontramos es la
velocidad mínima o la rapidez mínima que
tendría que tener y eso es porque
queremos tener este margen de seguridad
queremos tener tracción con el camino y
no queremos ir demasiado rápido porque
la fuerza de la gravedad podría ser
bastante grande y quizás
haremos de esto en un vídeo futuro pero
para tener esto relacionado a kilómetros
por hora vamos a calcular sacamos de
nuevo la calculadora
esto está en metros por segundo
encontramos cuántos metros por ahora hay
multiplicando esto por 3600 segundos por
hora y estos son nuestros metros por
hora
ahora vamos a dividirlo entre mil para
encontrar los kilómetros y son 55
kilómetros por hora así que esto es
aproximadamente igual a 55 kilómetros
por hora
el conductor aquí afortunadamente tuvo
un margen de seguridad en su velocidad o
en su rapidez de manera que superó la
velocidad mínima para mantener este
movimiento circular y seguramente tenía
una muy buena tracción con el camino